مشروع 11 الثاني 2022
نرحب
الجميل حان كاس العالم العالم في قطر
اليوم رحله الاثني عشر عاما منذ فازت قطر
الدوله الخليجيه العربيه المسلمه عام 2010
باستضافه اكبر واهم حدث رياضيا في العالم
رحله يقول اهل قطر انها سنوات من التحدي
وانهم على وعدهم بتنظيم ما ياملون ان يكون
اجمل نسخه في تاريخ البطوله تقام لاول مره
في الشرق الاوسط
العرب في كاس العالم كان دوما وجود ضيف
بمشاركه منتخباتهم اثنا عشر مرات منذ بدي
اياها عام
1930 لكنهم اليوم حاضرون باربعه منتخبات
وهم المضيفونه والمنظم
[موسيقى]
للمره الاولى سيرى القادمون سحر الشرقي
حيث هو لا مستشرقا او متخيلا مرويا او
مشوهان ويرون ثقافه الاسلاميه والعربيه
وعاداتها في اهلها المتباهين بها لا من
تصورات نمطيه مسبقه صنعتها السياسه
والدعايه ويردد المسؤولون القطريون بان
هذا التنظيم هو باسم كل العرب ومنهم
للعالم اجمع فرصه تتجاوز الرياضه لتلاقي
الثقافات واكتشاف الاخر وكسر الحواجز
الانسانيه في ظلال لوحه هي في معناها شجره
وارثه في الصحراء
وكثيرا من صحراء الرمال الخلابه ثبت فيها
الروح مع نهضه شامله تعرف برؤيه 20 30 وهي
خطه نهوض في البنيه التحتيه والمشاريع
الضخمه في قطر تضمنت بناء مدن وشبكه
مواصلات حديثه بموازاه تطوير تعليميه
وصحيا جاء كاس العالم في وسط المسيره
لتشهد تسريعا في التنفيذ بكلفه تجاوزت 200
مليار دولار اقل من 10% منها كلفه 8 ملاعب
سيوهب بعضها لدول فقيره بينما يبقى
العمران والتحديث لاهله الحدث وفق كثيرين
الهام ومثال لان لا مستحيله مع الاراده
اما القدره فبالتخطيط والمال وان قوس ف
بالموارد طبيعيه وبشريه حين تحسنه اذارتها
بالنسبه لقطر
هذه مناسبه فريده لتثبيت حضور عالميا مع
انظار خمسه مليارات انسان ستتوجه اليها
لمتابعه كاس اكثر الرياضات شعبيه في
العالم وقت قصير يفصل عن صفاره البدايه
كان سنوات ثم ايام صدقائق ليشتعل الحماس
وتعود ذكريات وتتخلق التفاصيل نقاش
الاهداف والحروب الجميله على الفراق
والنجوم العابرين للحدود والاعراف والزمن
لشهر ستتخفف الانسانيه من غلوائها وتنشغله
بصراع قانونه فوري نفاذ وميدانه منازلات
وانتصارات لا بطش فيها ولا دماء لهذا ربما
يعشق الناس كره القدم اذ تمنحهم عداله
تغيب في الحياه وتتحقق في ملعبه حيث
البقاء للافضل لا للاكثر او الاغنام او
الاقوى
[تصفيق]